you are responsible for your life you're
saying the way that my life has been is
no longer how it's going to be so maybe
three tips on how to actually execute
that the brilliant insight that changes
everything for people is realizing that
responsibility is never given it's taken
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message
take responsibility over to you Oprah
Winfrey also if you want to hear at
Oprah and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series I
have paid attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you real work
is to figure out where your power base
is every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a 30 second to 5 minute
video for free every morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below
you are responsible for your life and if
you're sitting around waiting on
somebody to save you to fix you to even
help you you are wasting your time
because only you have the power to take
responsibility to move your life forward
and the sooner you get that the sooner
your life gets into gear what matters is
now this moment and your willingness to
see this moment for what it is accept it
forgive the past take responsibility and
move forward where you are right now
does not have to be where you end up the
choice is yours
Oprah is one of my favorite stories of
all time to prove this case I think too
often we become a victim of our
circumstances you think that you are
here and you will always be here and
it's somebody else's fault
it's the president's followed this your
environments fault is your parents fault
is the government's fault it's the
school's fault so is somebody else's
fault and that is your excuse to say
exactly where you are until you look in
the mirror and you say this is this is
my responsibility I can't help where I
was born and I can't help who my parents
were and all these other things that
happened to you what as long as you
accept that as your story then your
constant living in the past
you can change it's never been easier to
win in any environment you can change
you can win this is the best it's your
responsibility
Oprah is when i favorite examples
because i like to tell her story and and
how she grew up and the circumstances
are crazy like you think whatever in
your life is so bad look at Oprah's
story being abused growing up being
raised by her grandmother and bounced
around between homes being so poor is
one of my favorite ones being so poor
that her grandma couldn't afford to buy
her clothes so she would go to the
grocery store buy potatoes because they
need to eat potatoes and she would take
the big potato bag and so that into a
dress that up would wear to school
can you imagine as a kid can you imagine
like you as a kid going to school
dressed up in a potato bag that was your
clothing you were so poor that you had
to go to school in a potato bag the
amount of abuse
and hatred and negativity and how many
jokes had be hurled your way and to go
from that everything against her to
where she is it seems impossible it
seems crazy but that's a story of so
many successful entrepreneurs it's a
story of so many successful people it's
very rare that the children of
successful people gwah to do successful
things the people have everything lined
up for them all the money all the
resources all the education all the
connections everything they really go
off to do the things that are amazing
they really become the big game changes
themselves their parents were but they
aren't look at your heroes look at the
people who you look up to and respect
the people who you want to emulate and
be like and learning from and model look
at their story look at where they came
from
change the thought that came from
nothing chances are they came from a
place that is less than what you already
have right now and I use that as
inspiration I use that as if they could
do it I could do it too look what where
they came from if they can go from there
to where they are now what's your Excuse
why can't you the difference is just
accept the responsibility the difference
is saying I'm not waiting at anybody
I don't need anybody to give me a chance
there's nobody else's fault I mean I
even be your fault yet but now you're
taking responsibility you're saying the
way that my life has been is no longer
how it's going to be so you need me
three tips on how to actually execute
that the first is release your parents
we default to blaming our parents for
where we are I have a great example in
my book your one word where I tell the
story of two different MBA players both
are all-stars and one of them says I'm
here because my parents could have the
best parents in the world because they
taught me everything about how to be a
great human being and I'm here as a
tribute to them because of how much they
believed in me and the other guy said
I'm here because my parents I had the
worst parents in the world I never want
to be like them I'm here because I
worked hard because I never want the
life that they had and they're both NBA
all-stars with totally opposite parents
given sides of the spectrum it's not how
your parents were growing up it's your
reaction to them you might have had
great parents and you want to make them
proud or you might have had terrible
parents that I never want to be like
them again either way
release them and say this is my life now
I don't know how old you are watching
this video you know if you're nine years
old it might be hard you know you still
have a couple years left of living your
parents life what they want for you but
as you become an adult you need to
decide at what point do you release your
parents I got what point is of stop
being your parents fault and now you
need to pick up the mantle and run with
your life and at 16 is it 18 is it 20 is
it twenty five is thirty if you're 45
years old are you still blaming your
parents for your circumstances you're
still blaming them for where you are in
life at what point do you pick up the
mantle and say this is my life
I'm responsible for it and so I hope
that moment is now I hope if you are you
know over 18 years old I hope that I
hope that it's now I hope that you say
okay it's not my parents fault anymore I
can't keep living in the past and
tomorrow can be a bright a day a next
year can be a brighter year if I decide
to make it so release your parents SEP 2
is released or circumstances that's the
next most common thing people blame
their circumstances that I grew up in
this area and education government and
country and you don't know what it's
like and I can't escape this people are
victim of their circumstances but again
people have done it people have broken
through some of the best people in the
world again the people you look up to
and respect and want to be like they
broke through they made it they made it
happen and the only difference was that
mindset shift that I need to get out of
here I need to go make my own I refuse
to be here the rest of my life so you
need to release your circumstances
whatever has happened has happened and
in many cases that's the best like the
people who went off and did those great
things they all came from tough
upbringing from tough circumstances from
tough surroundings the people who who
hit it that's where they came from it's
very rare that came from the upper class
or upper middle class skim phone to a
difference place you could be like them
if you stop being the victim of your
circumstance if you decide that this
that everything that happened to me this
made me strong this may be awesome this
is making me a survivor I'm tough now
because of this and it's gonna fuel my
growth and I will no longer be here
anymore
that in one year from today I'm not
going to be in the same place that I'm
at right now
release your circumstances and set
number three is do something right now
just take some kind of action take that
big dream that you have and find some
small way to get started immediately I
just came back from Boston I was doing
this speech at Boston speaks and I give
that same thing at the end and I said
hey guys do something right now
like most important piece of advice do
something right now and this woman in
the audience got up and she said I've
always wanted to make a video so I'm
gonna make a video right now in front of
everybody she made her first video I had
that happen so many times of different
entrepreneurs it's like I've always
wanted to make videos I've always wanted
to tell a story on snapchat or
instagrams like okay let's do one right
now it's gonna suck but that's okay you
suck at everything at the beginning the
most important part is that you've done
something that you've taken some kind of
action that you've made your first video
that you've taken your first step so
whatever you want to do whatever your
big 5-year playing or lifelong mission
that you want to accomplish is great and
that can be inspiring but when it's so
big
often we feel like well it's never gonna
happen until we get venture capital
funding until somebody takes a shot on
you you don't need that person take a
shot on you take a shot on yourself bet
on yourself let's see it happen some
small action today now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know what is that one
small may be insignificant action that
you were going to do to build any kind
of momentum for your big vision you've
got your big dream you're gonna do one
thing today to help move it a little
tiny inch closer to happening what is
that one thing you're gonna do leave it
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
to for a really long time that school is
a scam that teaches people to be
compliant that tells you to only listen
to things that are on the test it
encourages you to do the minimum amount
because whatever you get away was the
rest of the times yours that's what we
teach you in school we invented that so
that you would get a factory job and do
what you were told
because factories needed it so that's
why they invented school and the
brilliant insight that changes
everything for people is realizing that
responsibility is never given it's taken
and if you choose to take responsibility
all these doors open up and that you get
a totally different life in exchange
because striving for authority hoping
someone will give you a license to tell
other people what to do that's pretty
rare but if you're willing to take
responsibility then no one can get in
your way
we did this movie where I played this
guy where he said you know what uh
you know what see
[Applause]
so I I did I played Ray Charles and I
either but I'm gonna make it do what you
do baby
and when we play Ray Charles we didn't
know what we were doing in that movie
that was an independent movie it went on
to get nominated for an Oscar here was a
problem when we got nominated for an
Oscar thought there's no way we win so I
use that as an excuse to throw parties
let's turn up right yeah then I get a
call for somebody hi Jamie Fox this is
Oprah I'm like who yeah what what who
that is Oprah she says you're blowing it
I said what you mean oh she says you got
an opportunity to do something great
walk into the history books and you're
blowing it and I need to help you with
it and I said well I'm sorry what I need
to do so she took me to Quincy Jones's
house Oh
and Quincy came out hey Mel hey man
you're doing great job with Ray man and
you man you really did that man I
remember Michael and I'm 54 million
records with Thriller baby I remembered
that man but you have to walk a certain
way Jamie because you don't want to blow
it man everybody's counting on your
mouth and I said thank you and he takes
me into his house and there was people
from the 60s and the 70s that have been
actors and actresses all dressed up to
say walk the right way do the right
thing cuz we counting on you because we
never would have thought this would
happen and so Oprah comes up she says I
wanted to do this for you because you
need to understand the significance of
things and a lot of times people don't
understand that she says now are you
ready to meet the person that you're
here for I said yeah and standing over
in the corner was Sidney Poitier
Wow go up to Sidney Poitier and Sidney
Poitier I mean you know I saw you one
time just do do anybody nice he said I I
saw you at the party
do you remember that and I was I just
started crying I was like yeah and he
says your performance made me grow two
inches and I was like I appreciate it he
says Oprah and I would like to give you
one thing I said what's that
responsibility so you're responsible for
your art you responsible for this moment
and so that's the Oprah Winfrey who took
that moment to where I could have blew
it in the club and we ended up walking
through and making history and everybody
felt eristic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video